半年前我跟他讲过，
我说我给你机会，
你自己选，
你跟他分不开，
我就成全你，
我退出，
你转给我的，
你想拿走多少，
你自己算是这样的律士。
我呢，
结婚两年半多，
快三年，
在超级一线城市，
我结婚前个人资产就两三百万吧，
对方呢，
工作比我晚两年，
自己个人资产就少一些，
我是研究生才是本科生，
婚前呢，
我发现他用交友软件约我，
当时挺纠结的，
他呢，
为了表示诚意，
他就把他手上所有的存款呀，
基金啊，
反正就转给我，
表示他这个诚意，
包括后面这种月薪啊也都转给我，
我当时觉得蛮有诚意的，
他犯这样一次错误，
最后还是决定原谅他就结婚了。
但是同时一个问题就是我没有，
我没有做的婚前财产的隔离，
其实现在是一个很穷的状态，
问题是出在半年前，
我又发现他又有人了，
在外面是他的同事，
就是发签了之后有没有做什么措施呢？
比如签个协议啊什么的，
我有试着去找律师写了让他签就不肯签，
他就觉得他有卖身的感觉，
就不肯签，
因为我当时觉得过不下去了，
只能分开。
我爸爸妈就觉得他还蛮好的，
因为我爸也不知道他有婚前约的情况，
我也从来没讲过，
然后我爸就觉得这个孩子对我平时日常是很照顾，
很细致，
就是不想。
让我分开吧，
然后我呢也跟他谈，
他就说一些我的问题，
什么家务做的不好啊，
脾气不好啊，
我让他感觉到压抑啊，
我跟他在私密的那个，
嗯，
他也不是很满意，
他提出之后，
我就觉得我确实也舍不得分开，
我就这半年很努力去改变，
去迎合他说的他的那些喜好，
包括他指出的我的问题，
我都努力去改正，
但是最近几天我发现他们俩又联系上了，
现在双方父母也都知道他的态度呢，
其实他想分开了，
他这个人说话因为是很反复的那种，
今天想分开，
明天不想分开，
我觉得他就是立场也很不坚定，
但是呢，
其实我看得出他其实已经比较想要分开了，
他也了解我的，
我这种人就是很直来直去，
其实我不能接受刘波的这种出那个的情况，
我可能会一直疑疑鬼，
想很多，
也很内耗，
他对于冠面那个人，
他也觉得挺有感情的，
他也跟人家分不掉那个样子，
现在呢，
其实我基本上决定要分开了，
有两点问题想跟你请教一下，
一个呢，
是我的资产跟他的已经混同了，
婚前婚后啊，
都混在一起了，
然后他的呢，
现在其实都在我的账户里，
就银行卡呀，
理财账户，
就是等于说在我自己的名字下面，
嗯，
就是。
哎，
不好意思，
我你有点，
我我明白你了，
我明白你的诉求了，
因为你婚前没有做财产的隔离，
婚后财产和婚前的财产又放到一块儿去了，
那么现在如果要分手的话，
你的损失会很大，
现在你想要的诉求是我怎么能够把我的损失降低，
最起上是保证我自己的财产，
婚前的那一部分是归我个人的，
是这个意思对不对？
是的是的，
然后还有一点呢，
是他现在比较怕我去他公司闹，
我接下来给你讲的就是这个话题，
我觉得比较公平的做法啊，
他挣的钱还给他，
你的婚前的财产，
包括你婚后的财产，
你自己拿，
如果说他认为他愿意对于对你造成的伤害给予补偿啊，
不管是10万也好，
8万也好，
他有这个意思，
你愿意接纳，
那这个很好，
但如果他没有这个意思，
他已经做好了准备，
彻底要跟你分开，
他也不想吃亏的话，
那对于你来说，
能够保证所有婚前的财产是归你一个人的，
且你婚后挣的是归你了，
然后他的钱还给他，
对于你来说也是一个很好的结局，
为什么？
因为一旦你们俩打官司的话，
就是对半分，
因为你婚前财产和婚后财产混同了，
放在一个锅里了，
在这种情况下，
你不能证明那些钱。
是你婚前的存款的情况下，
对于法官来说的话，
对保险的说法就是对半分，
彭律师，
就是我之前也咨询过律师也讲的跟您讲的差不多，
就是这个在法律上的界定，
但是还有一个思路，
就是说一个呢是银行那边，
现在我们咨询过我婚前大部分的那个银行，
他们说可能是拉不出领证前一天资产的一个走的情况，
但是那个律师还给我提一个思路，
就是说你可以把你们现在所有的减掉，
我跟他在一起之后花销的再减掉，
他转给我的，
那是不是剩下的就能证明剩下的钱是我的这样一个不借，
这样也可以吗？
不可以，
钱这个东西它是不记名的，
我给你举一个例子啊，
就像这杯水，
我昨天喝剩下半杯水，
然后我今天又往里面倒了半杯水，
现在这杯水是满杯的，
然后我喝了以后又剩半杯，
请问谁能分得清楚剩下来这半杯水是我昨天剩下的，
还是我今天倒进去的？
这个逻辑想明白了吗？
这个逻辑我懂啊，
但是这个谁改谁，
这个都是有记录的吗？
就是这个转账记录不能证明什么吗？
你的婚后的这个钱是你花对不对？
那你花出去的钱，
你怎么能够说明花出去的钱一定是我婚后挣的呢？
是这样的啊，
我不知你谁花的就钱。
算在我头上，
就是等于说我从跟他领证后，
所有的支出全算我头上，
因为目前为止我俩在一块儿也没一起买房子，
也没孩子，
我能理解你的意思，
你的意思就是说你老公转给你的钱都退给他，
然后剩下的都是你的了，
你的逻辑是这样对不对？
怎么讲，
我不甘心把他转给我的就这么还给他，
那对他来讲啊，
我就是结了一个婚，
我不开心了，
我就分开，
然后我的钱还是我的钱，
对他来说没有损失啊，
对，
人家下一代都找好了，
我就是没了家庭，
我还多一个那个证儿，
我能理解你姑娘啊，
其实作为任何一个女性，
我们都能理解你心里难受吗？
对吧，
我也没做错任何的事情，
我突然变成二婚了，
我在经济上还产生了一定的损失，
我能理解你，
但是我们要看到事实，
现在的事实就是因为我们自己不了解法律，
也对人不设防，
所以我们现在是已经站在烈士的地位了，
我们现在烈士的地位是对于我们来说，
我们婚前的财产也是有风险的了，
那在这种情况下，
我们需要做的是什么？
是需要尽量的降低这个风险，
控制这个损失，
那么龙飞律师刚刚跟你讲了，
就是相对比较理性的一种做法，
能够控制你的损失，
不然的话，
随着时间的推移，
日子越长，
你们的婚姻关系越久。
那么你的这个财产被二一天做我分给他一半的可能性就越大，
明白这个意思啊，
就是我能做定住你的那种不平，
但是我要面对这个客观的事实，
这个客观的事实就是我们自己好不容易婚前攒的这些存款，
现在处于一种不确定的风险状态，
有的律师可能会告诉你啊，
法官可能会考虑到这个因素啊，
有的律师可能会告诉你，
大概率下就是一人一半这么分，
因为你财产混同了，
这两种可能性都会发生。
现实生活中也有的法官他可能会照顾你一点，
比如你拿出你自己曾经的那些收入证明，
证明你婚前就有200万、
300万的存款，
可能这个法官会照顾你一点，
但是万一这个法官他不照顾你呢？
因为这个法官他照顾你是人情之外的东西，
他不照顾你，
他按照法律判就是一人一半，
理解这个逻辑了吗？
理解了啊，
所以你现在如果他害怕你去他单位去闹的话，
你可以心平苦和的跟他讲，
你说我们就好聚好散，
我也不想占你的便宜，
你转给我多少钱我都退给你，
然后我们签一个夫妻财产约定书，
约定好我们没有共同的债务，
我们也没有共同的财产，
各自名下的存款归各自所有，
这样的话就能保住你名下的存款是归你个人了啊，
你说的这种我其实半年。
前想过，
我那时候其实是可以接受这个条件的，
但是因为我又努力了半年，
现在我就不太能接受这样的分配了，
因为半年前我跟他讲过，
我说我给你机会，
你自己选，
你跟他分不开，
我就成全你，
我退出，
你想给我的，
你想拿走多少你自己算，
就是我给他这样拼我，
他那时候就是一考虑下来还是选择跟我在一起，
我这半年就很努力的去迎合他，
我每天过的都不好，
但是我在他面前尽量装作没有事情，
我比较开心，
我想把日子过好，
我拿出一个我的态度，
方方面面，
但是他还是这样对我，
我觉得你这个问题最关键的症结点在于什么？
症结点在于你心里要接纳一个兜底的一个结果，
这个兜底的结果就是你的钱归他的钱归他，
当你心里有了这样一个兜底的结果，
你跟他谈才有可能谈出一个好的结果，
听见没有啊，
我今天为什么不跟你聊这么多，
我就是希望打开你心里这个心结，
让你即便是有一天啊，
钱退了他了之后，
你心里也能过得去，
就因为我们成年人要为自己的行为买单的，
你在这件事情的过程当中并不是完全无辜的，
原因是什么？
因为你在进货之前就知道他。
那么秘密就给了你一次机会，
让你疼你，
这样的结局，
那你你选择了什么？
你自己选择了继续跟他结婚，
当可能就是选择埋下了这个种子，
到今天发芽了，
你要去承担这个结果，
是我当时很犹豫很犹豫，
当时我妈妈做一个开颅手术，
家里也很希望我能定下来，
哎呀，
看到他又很有诚意，
我就我就走下去了，
当然这不说明我都没说完，
这是一方面，
就是我们凡是当我们发现很多因果关系在我们自身也是有影响的时候，
我们才愿意接纳今天的这个结果，
这是一方面，
就是当你在婚前发现他PK了之后，
你仍然跟他走进了婚姻，
这是我们自己应该承担的果。
另一个方面是什么？
另一方面是我们自己婚前的这些财产，
我们在走进婚姻的时候，
居然没有想过做任何的保护措施，
这是不是我们自己的责任，
是是当你想通这两个点了之后，
你今天就更有可能去接纳说啊，
大不了就是我的钱归我，
你的钱归你，
回来就好聚好散就行了，
就也别想通那再给你多少钱啊，
给你弄这成啊什么的了，
就这意思啊，
好好好好，
拜拜，
谢谢龙律师，
我知道大家可能会觉得，
哎呀，
龙飞律师啊，
本来就约定都10分钟，
你为什么加加加要加那么长时间，
就是因为我知道我直播。
那有很多人都会有相同类似的心结，
这个心结在你心里打不开的话，
他可能会困你十年，
困你八载，
但如果说这个心结在龙飞姐这里，
我今天帮你们都打开了的话，
你就会发现，
或许我在一段不好的婚姻里面出来，
这件事情我自己当初也有我选择的问题，
也有我妥协的问题，
也有我自己没有保护好自己财产的这样一个问题，
不能把所有的责任都归结于他怎么怎么样了，
那这个时候我们在面对今天的这个现状的时候，
我们的心里就更容易去接纳一点，
这大家同意吗？
有没有人被我刚才讲的那段话解开了心结，
这就是龙飞律师我做这份工作的意义，
我在回答一个人问题的时候，
其实并不是解决一个人的问题，
是解决很多人心里面的那个结，
有很多姐妹，
她面对一段失败的婚姻，
被背叛的情感的时候，
他就总是走不出来啊，
总是觉得自己是那个受伤害的，
总是接纳不了这样的结局，
那么这个就会困你十年八载的，
那你一旦有一天你想明白了这个理儿，
想明白了这个逻辑了之后，
你就会发现，
其实我也不冤，
我得到这样的结局，
跟我当初做的决定，
跟我当初的想法，
跟我当初的认知是有关联的，
是有因果的，
刚刚有个姐妹，
她真的被困了8年，
是不是希望所有的姐妹你们？
不能打开自己的心结，
接纳自己，
接纳自己的过往，
就是当有一天我们完全接纳了自己，
也接纳了自己的过往，
也愿意承担自己过往的决策所带来的今天的结果的时候，
好，
我们就变得自由了，
也强大了。